[Music]
hello and welcome to another fireside
chat you can tell it's a fireside chat
because of that professional video shot
in my dirty closet so we have a panel of
experts here on stage we also have more
engineers in the audience to handle
hopefully anything you can throw at us
so let me set some ground rules we're
looking for interesting technical
questions we are not looking for
questions that go something like when
will Android will the platform anything
with the word will or any future thing
you can guarantee we're not going to
give an interesting answer to it we
don't really talk about futures but we'd
like to talk about everything else so
let me start this out by actually
introducing the panel I'm Chet Haase and
from the Android toolkit team I'm Diane
Hepburn I imagine the android framework
team
I'm Anwar Kalume I'm responsible for
core OS and Android I'm Steph I'm the
director of product management developer
relations for developer platform
I'm Arash I work on Play Store mahoma
I'm not sure what I do anymore neither
is anybody else
I'm Paul Bankhead I'm the p.m. for the
Play Store
I'm tor from Android studio microphone I
work in the toolkit team and so in past
fireside chats
we've pre-rolled questions from Twitter
from the interwebs and we didn't do that
this year without be interesting to just
take the live questions from the crowd
the fact that nobody is standing up at
the microphones means this may be an
extremely short session I would invite
any and all questions with the caveat
that I gave before from the audience
please come up to the microphone so that
the live stream and so that the
recording can actually catch what you're
saying and so that we can as well looks
like we have our first coming up to the
microphone so just form queues really
really long and painful and tedious
queues that the microphones and we'll
take them one by one until we're done
Thanks yes please
I have a couple questions about some of
the libraries I'd like to start off with
the Android job priority queue
and so yes I'm wondering if with all the
new ways to manage jobs in the
background if you would still suggest
using that particular library or would
you suggest something else so for people
who don't know this is like a job
scheduler library before there was a job
scheduler that I wrote in my previous
job no I'm just lazy to duplicate it I
work closely with the work manager team
like I think definitely the way to go
hopefully I will have some time and
duplicate the library you should have
used anymore would you suggest using if
you want a job to be done in the
background but relatively quickly not
like like in the middle of the night but
with internet you know a few minutes an
hour or something like that so work
major actually does try to run it faster
compared to job schedule like it doesn't
delegate to the job scheduler
immediately it also tries to run it
itself so work manager will work most of
the use cases when you're designing web
manager we looked at like should we
create something that both can run like
deferred jobs and the instant jobs the
problem is you cannot really define a
good API that works for both of them and
if you are trying to run them in memory
instantly there is like a much better
API with codecs and stuff so we decided
to keep them separate if anyone knows
anything about Glide
there's on glide for we've got lied and
glide app and I'm just curious if I
could maybe have someone from the glide
maybe explain some of the differences
with it no I don't think we have people
from the glide library here but does
anybody on the panel use go ahead before
or have opinions besides we do recommend
that people use that and not write your
own bitmap cashing library because why
yes there are other ones as well Picasso
is reasonable approach but I'm not sure
what your question was it's not answered
by that vague perception yes
Thanks yep I'll say there are two mics
too if one line gets really long be sure
to seek out the other one hi hi since I
cannot ask questions I'm going to just
make a comment so I noticed that you are
now opinionated and that's excellent you
have limited your opinion so for example
is SIL there is no dependency injection
there are suggestions may be used at
your - there are suggestions about using
our extra a certain times sometimes
there are conflicts between the
suggestions yeah I'm not gonna ask when
you're gonna have those incorporated
into what you're doing today I'm just
suggesting that maybe you should
consider that and have those also so
that we don't have to go make choices so
if I could rephrase that I just say
would you consider and then I'll put a
question mark at the end and then it'll
be about not really I was going to ask
when you are going to do that ok I doubt
we're gonna answer that question was
there anyone I wanted to address the
underlying thing not like dependency
injection is one of terrors we are
looking at expanding but we want to be
careful and slow so I want to make sure
the things we have already shipped are
iterated very well and as we get more
headcount I don't know challenge more
problems I should point out - this came
up in conversations yesterday that we
were having with some developers we have
opinions now but those opinions we hope
don't approach the the area of arrogance
where we say this is absolutely the way
you should do it always it's more that
we are providing opinions on reasonable
ways to write applications if you have
other opinions if you have existing
architectures or ways that you need to
do it instead we absolutely think you
should use those approaches and this
includes the use of other libraries and
other approaches out there we don't want
to take the place of things that are
there they're working reasonably well
for people already why would we bother
doing that right so yes we do have
opinions but we one of those opinions is
use what is right for you in your
application I still don't have opinions
so like the underlying platform is still
neutral and like what we're doing this
building you know on top of it some
opinion set that to make it easier for
people to use I'm pretty sure you have
opinions you just don't want to see them
yes hey my name is Shane I'm with Jaguar
Land Rover so ever since I first heard
about Kotlin last year sounds like
something really interesting I've
practiced it a little bit on my own but
the reality is I'm not gonna be able to
start getting deeper into it until I can
get organizational buy-in just which
from Java to Kotlin and at a company
like mine which is a big automotive
company it's not a software company
getting that sort of buy-in is really
difficult so do you guys have any
strategies or tips to kind of sell that
up to manage it and slash are there any
resources that you guys have that we can
use to kind of help present a technical
and business case to use content more at
work so first of all Christina Lee had a
couple talks last year I think on this
exact topic how to convince organization
to adopt cotton so you should check
those out okay be like we have some data
on like developer productivity developer
productivity data it might help we do
know that people who are using it are
very very happy and you know it's also
it could be an easier way to attract
talent if that's difficult for you to
find really good under developer say you
know it seems that a lot of Pro
developers really prefer to use : and so
they might be more excited to come you
know work for you if you can offer them
complan it's actually pretty cool to see
that thun inked and emails from
recruiters where they say and we use
cutting and superc i'm like that's real
twitter language as a perk so just some
more data in our surveys which have an
end of like 17,000 the delta between
Kotlin and any other language it's about
20 to 25 points higher absolute in terms
of satisfaction and what's interesting
is the more developers use cotton we
measure that the higher that
satisfaction gets which the first time I
saw that I was like is that an error and
Joe's never get to happier over time
yeah so it was very interesting data um
the other thing that we're finding is
generally the companies that are using
cotton are finding they have a kind of
whole classes
errors that go away so the quality of
the code is significantly higher and
also their productivity is higher at one
of the things that is useful is you end
up writing a lot less code and code you
don't write doesn't have bugs in it I
think it's if I was gonna phrase the
question back to you if we produce a
series of concrete case studies that
kind of documented that would that be
useful to you yeah that's exactly what
I'm getting at okay mr. Katsaros right
in front of you I think we should
probably do some of those we did one he
says okay what's that oh he says he says
did you watch the keynote it was in it
well sure about it I just it's not
readily available for me to share the
keynote right so so yeah anything and
I've talked to several other developers
here who worked for like maybe financial
institutions rather kind of like these
non software companies that don't get it
so any any case studies or any
statistics you guys can put up like in a
one-stop shop that could be sent to a
manager that would be really useful so
many other people in the audience if we
produced a series of case studies you
know like valid case studies on Kotlin
that would be useful to you raise your
hand Wow okay let's of it thank you very
much for this thank you
you have alerted the right people also
as a general rule if you're trying to
convince business executives I find the
charts and graphs help Thanks yes but if
you could ask questions that don't lead
to more work for us that would be great
hey guys
bunch of tooling questions I'll start
with easy one can we make Clint
incremental it in our projects for
context it takes about an hour on 32
cores 180 28 gigs of RAM machines and we
shard it now Tory you wrote too much
lint code yeah it's a very difficult
problem and I had this conversation with
a couple of people yesterday and
unfortunately for them what they're
doing right now is they want to have
every CL they upload actually also run
through all the lint to make sure that
you don't accidentally directly my plan
is to make lint five to ten times slower
over the next year Oh things right and
I'm doing that because I want to add
more checks I'm gonna look for things
more deeply do add more whole program
analysis and I think for most people
it's it's more important for link to
find more bugs than furtive run
and so I would recommend instead running
lint as a post submit thing right so
that it runs maybe every night and then
you find out afterwards hey this CL
broke something I understand they would
be nicer if it was fast but I'm saying
that the primary goal of lint is to be
really comprehensive and for us to keep
adding more checks and that is the
opposite of trying to make it run faster
if there was some low-hanging fruit or
making faster I would love to do it we
went well I mean you can mark all the
inputs as like inputs cacheable and I
think we just did that in four but I
there's a lot more work to make it run
you know in parallel yeah that's all
right
but that that'll be like eventual
integration if you're on earth post yeah
I know that there are people on the
Gradle team who actually are looking
into making lint run faster it's just
that we don't see a lot of low-hanging
fruit and it again it's not at least not
my top priority all right this is a
second one from it so there is basil
right let me start that way there was
basil con the basil is open source so
it's not something that is in the future
the basil is here but what Android teams
think about it every time you add
another language or build system or IDE
it's a lot more work right so when we
started working on enter studio we
stopped working on Eclipse because
trying to maintain sort of oh you want
Eclipse will have this plugin for you
all you want to tell Joe here's his
other plug-in there's a lot to be gained
when you focus on making one thing work
really well and so right now we are
focusing on making great all work as
well as it as we can make it fair enough
yeah right thanks
yes hi so back in the day like back in
2011 we had Android App Inventor
actually we I used to use it to teach it
to kids in the summer camps and it was
like a good no code tool but then it got
deprecated and like I was just curious
like do you guys have any like is any no
code framework which we can use right
now just I think that what happened was
that it's been taken over by I want to
say MIT I'm not sure exactly which
universe did get absorbed in some of the
project yeah I think they're still
developing it
one of my daughter's is using it in
college okay okay so like means but they
were not a lot of updates coming in so
yeah we're not working on it oh I think
that it was originally maybe developed
together you know academia and Google
we're not working on that right now but
would you like us to work on it
what what in particulars that you like
about it is the is it the no source file
like this the actual visual programming
or is it the component based development
of sort of taking ready-made not just
widgets but things like select
accelerometers and who can those up like
what specifically is it that you want so
like when I was using it for teaching it
to kids right like means in in the third
or the fourth grade like means it's
really exciting for them to just develop
an app and at that time it like it was
intuitive for me as well so I was just
thinking like if something is there
since we are already working on so many
tools if there's just one more no code
tool it will help us out and the kids
can start developing apps for Apple
thank you for your request
yeah we'll add it to our to-do list it's
pretty long at this point just one more
question so any recommended tool for
using si ICD you know Android like means
there is no like means we can use
Jenkins and that's fine but do you guys
recommend any tool to be used for SI ICD
any the experts wanna say anything about
this I don't think we've picked I don't
think we picked one that we recommend oh
stuff so we have a talk later today on
project nitrogen which is a pretty
interesting project where we want to
give you something that you can scale
your testing and so you might want to
check that that's I should not okay okay
thanks thanks yes all right
does the Android team view flutter as a
growing core that developers in this
room should focus on and on learning or
should we expend those learning
resources on deeper Android SDK
knowledge well so we do a lot of things
at Google flutter is one of them and you
know Android as always is all about
choice I
you realize flutter there's a lot of
interesting things but you know we just
made kathleen an official language on
android we're not going to make dart an
official language on android and you
know for our s qualities that are very
interesting to sometimes server
applications out there as already
cross-platform you should if we look
into it it's worth a look but you know
it's not something we are adopting
ourselves on the Android team alright
thank you that's yes hello my name is
bond we're from Brazil thanks for that
any work that you have done for Android
community everyone is grateful here I
have two questions one is regarding
instant run I was talking to some
friends few weeks ago and all of them
like disables tantrum to work like and
daily basis and if you look for isn't
running on the Google every time like
the tree or fourth suggestion is like
how can I disable that run to program
what's the current scenario of Stanford
like are you guys putting some efforts
to put in some effort it's kind of not
working as could be but how is a great
scenario yeah so we described in the
keynote yesterday I think that we're
working on project marble which is
really about reworking things that are
kind of broken and focusing on product
excellence right fixing bugs UI freezes
leaks those kinds of things and instant
run is one of those things where we're
working pretty deeply on I think we did
we talk about the EA yes we did so we're
already working with a few you know
early access users to test our new
implementation which is quite different
from the old one and we're pretty
optimistic about it but we don't we want
to make sure that we really test it well
before we say hey right now it's gonna
be great we are actively recruiting for
an EP right now for what we're doing
with instant runs so if you are
interested you can look for me or John
Sal okay Android studio booth awesome
and the second question is quickly and
what you guys think are you folks think
about remote development for example if
you don't have this kind of huge machine
with 16 gigabytes of RAM
how it's possible for me to have like
this kind of fast deployment on Android
I saw some libraries like wing framer
that can also deploy the application
come back if you have current connection
doesn't matter the hardware that you
have what you guys think about this kind
of remote deployment and like testing
with like remote ADB there's a lot of
stuff going on about this on community
what you guys think about Google is like
this kind of cloud first data first come
a company it would be cool to have
something let's not doesn't matter are
usually about like running tests in the
cloud or you don't know an actual live
debugging yeah I run an app it reads on
a very powerful machine on the cloud and
come back with the apk then I run on my
phone
I mean machine are you talking about the
device yeah your your computer okay so
you want studio so you say yeah remote
like a X terminal that's talking to it
like the yeah yeah maybe you can quote
like on your machine and then if you
need to like a fast deployment you can
have hit on the cloud or the point of it
basically X hosting should already work
right if you have Linux this should be
possible to you already but building
this in general is a little harder yeah
it's a great question it's one we we
talked about we've talked about it every
year for the last three years it's a I
think one of the advantages is it would
really help when you don't have a really
beefy machine yeah yeah and that is a
lot of users for those of you who opted
in we do watch the stats of you know how
much ram people have how much dis size
and it is you can expect it varies a lot
by geo only if people have opted in do
we look at those stats Ben so we worry a
lot about places where don't people
don't on average have as larger machines
it's a great question the challenge is
the cost of doing that and doing that
well is exceptionally high and probably
a lot of you in the audience are
familiar with many different efforts so
it's a long-running debate we have as
should we do this or should we because
doing that would postpone a lot of other
efforts so we're still having that
debate and you're I'd be great to have
you weigh in it you know it's it's just
really a trade-off decision yeah what
speaking because most of the people that
I talk about why they don't code for
Android you just because they don't have
a proper powerful machine so for example
if you have this kind of remote
deployment that you can like run the
application it would be good for for
example Google for education that have a
lot of Chromebooks that go have this
kind of local Android studio with a very
short hardware machine but with powerful
cloud machine that can build APIs or
something okay thank you so much thanks
hi a quick question about after you put
not repurchase you got acquired
crashlytics
into fire
like some functionalities are in the
firebase sighs is trying to I catch up
on the question exciting they're trying
to bring themselves up to my feature
parity but I can no longer search the
crashes on crashlytics or firebase why
is that deliberate is there anybody from
firebase or crashlytics rounds or is
that not part of the tools offering
anymore let me point out that Google's a
big company and we're not representative
of all the stuff that we're working on
right now I know some of the people on
the team and I also know that they're
not in the room so I don't think we can
actually answer that question right now
if you follow up afterwards we can get
back to you with an answer
cool thanks thanks hi I am Jason I work
at hinge and we've been a hundred
percent Kotlin for about two years now
and it's been dopin amazing and how did
you convince your executive management
to do that ah actually Cristina lien ty
Smith's their talks from Drake on two
and a half years ago yep like the
convincing factors so that was great and
wonderful amazing I have been working
really really hard at making the app as
good as I can with respect to CI and
test coverage and unit tests and
something that's been plaguing me for a
very long time is having code coverage
and getting the reporters to work
correctly with respect to Kotlin and the
40 Gradle modules that I have to
maintain when I run code coverage in
Android studio by the default Android
studio code coverage tool it works great
and amazing and then when I switch it to
J cocoa it says there's no coverage
found and essentially I have this very
strange copy pasted from stack overflow
scripts for J cocoa version zero seven
nine to seven bla that happens to work
and does happen to do correct reporting
but I feel like it's not documented
anywhere and
essentially I I'm not sure where to go
or like if I upgraded J cocoa or Kotlin
at some point I'm going to break this
and I do love cotton and I do love
Android studio in general I just want to
make this better what sounds like we
just need to fix the jacoco integration
with our Kotlin Gradle plugin or
integrate that Stack Overflow post into
the IDE yeah I'll make sure to talk to
the Gradle team and see what we can do
like can we follow up afterwards to get
the bug report from you I'm aware that
earlier on there were some code coverage
issues with Kotlin but we fixed a bunch
of those recently but apparently not all
of them yeah some of them have
definitely been fixed there was one
really weird bug where I could only run
unit tests on a single file at a time I
couldn't run it on an entire module if
we could follow up with you afterwards
and we can get the details Thanks hi hi
what is the reason behind the JVM base
instrumentation tests in robolectric for
dotto I am JVM instrumentation tests
yeah so now you can run Android tests
instead of on device you can write it on
JVM instead with robolectric for dot oh
yeah that's right so there's an you know
in Android there's two kinds of tests
there's local JVM tests and they're in
your test folder and then
instrumentation tests between your
android test folder you can use like
mockable jar or you can use robolectric
in those local tests what we're doing
with Android X tests is bringing a
unified testing API into Android X tests
because each mode of testing has
different api's and styles it's very
confusing for developers so in terms of
robolectric have just basically
implements the same API is that
instrumentation implements so you can
write the same tests in both local unit
tests and instrumentation so are you
merging the Android test folder in the
the normal unit test folder in the
Android studio and well I don't think
like there's actually been any decision
yet on that but and in terms of right
now you can use the same API is in both
we've got another talk today on project
nitrogen so if you think about the tests
or what you run project nitrogen sort of
is the how and the where and so I'd
encourage you to check that talk out
today is like 4:45 I believe and and
will you provide code coverage for both
unit tests and functional tests and we
would hope so thank you thanks ok I
Colin Liam from Minneapolis Mozilla I
have a question over the past eight
years or so writing apps like the one
API that's been the most bizarre hacks
for something that that's really basic
is working with the soft keyboard and
things like just opening the keyboard
listening to the state saying you want
to focus a particular element reliably
and shifting that the window and view so
that it focuses the elements you want to
write into or alter all those things if
they break on certain layouts are we
considering a rewrite of how keyboards
functions yeah yes we are many people
want to answer this question
Dianne you want to go first I'll let
others go any people's don't want to
answer this question it's something
we're looking into official release yeah
exactly so I mean we're we're well aware
of the kind of shortcomings that we've
got there we definitely want to enable
some richer integration with like
letting apps feel like the keyboard is a
part of your app experience more so than
like the bolt-on so we're actively
looking at it I think it's pretty
constant feedback over the last few
years that everybody's be very polite
about the cpas yes thank you
all right thanks hi hi I'm Mike so I
love Android studio and I love IntelliJ
I was lucky enough to actually start
working on IntelliJ as my first ID
rather than having to use the clips but
unfortunately sometimes it's a little
too heavy you know if we have emulators
up we have studio we have the browser
something like stefa 16 gigs is now
something that is not even optimal to do
Android development with and my manager
looks at me like I'm crazy when I tell
them that a 16 gig laptop that is
basically top-of-the-line isn't
something that I want to be coding on in
a daily basis so I know we can use you
know we can use them I can't use them
maybe other people can use them
we have sublime sublime also doesn't
really have some of the nice
autocomplete or doesn't have some of the
code navigation that I really got used
to using IntelliJ all these years so I
kind of want to ask is there ever been
something like an Android studio light
or some kind of plugins that anyone has
thought about doing because I I mean I
used to use a visual studio for
everything and then vias code came out
and you can now do a lot of that same
development just on smaller machines and
I would love to just bring my pixel book
here and still be able to do development
for work and be able to do it in non
studio so I kind of want to throw it up
if there's has ever been any thought
about doing tooling that would work in
things other than just IntelliJ platform
[Laughter]
does that help I mean that is not the
perfect we're not starting there I mean
it's very tempting to start with an
editor and try to build it up but
there's so much magic in IntelliJ that
they very hard to replicate what we're
doing with project marble is to try to
look at optimizing a lot of
inefficiencies right a lot of people
tell me that they're they have a 16 gig
machine and studio runs slowly on it but
they weren't aware and this is not their
fault by the way but they weren't aware
that studio is capped use at most one
point two gigs out of those 16 gigs
because there's a hard setting of
max-heap that studio gets and the only
way to make it use more of that is
actually you know going to edit the VM
config file I think if we don't start
interrupt but I think if we don't edit
it we're unable to use Android studio
yeah I know that's my issue with it I
don't want to edit it and give it four
or eight gigs but it's not a usable
experience we get pop up saying that we
don't give it more RAM yeah so one of
the things we want to do is to try to
auto configure that so you don't have to
do it we also want to try to reduce the
obvious inefficiency since some of the
things we're doing we're also looking at
disabling some plug-in sort of on demand
because some of them are pretty resource
intensive that maybe you aren't using so
I think our first
plan is to you know spend the next few
releases just really trying to optimize
things to work better as opposed to
starting a brand new tool anything else
good alright thank you thank you
hi I'm swapping in from CBS Interactive
so question regarding the data binding
library so I kind of have mixed opinion
regarding the using the data binding
library so I just want to ask like
technical is it like efficient or
anything then let's say using caught
linux ids does data binding as like
efficient benefits or something like
personally I don't like putting the code
inside XML
I just prefer don't put code inside
eczema the data binding doesn't require
you to put code eczema like we actually
Jose and I gave a talking droidcon two
weeks ago you can check that one out
like there is a misconception that just
because you can do it you should do it
like you don't put all of your code into
your activity either right we divide
your app so same things are valid in
data mining just because you can write
like complex expression doesn't mean you
should write in terms of efficiency yes
actually data binding like tries to
generate more efficient code than they
would normally write but is it like a
decision point definitely not it's not
going to make a big change you probably
have like a bigger fish to fry
but like I personally like you know I
worked on it and I used to use it in
other platforms before I do like the
declarative nature of data binding that
makes it like you just say put this
thing here and it eventually shows up
there but it's kind of a personal choice
like we have these things they are not
rules their opinions and we don't always
share the same opinion either if you
like it use it it's great and if you
don't like it that's like you don't have
to use anything okay it's like just
personal open an art that really helps
with the efficiency or anything yeah I
mean like it's is it is a like it is
efficient but it's not going to make a
big change for your application that's
the that's the problem that yes like
median
we try to generate better cotton that
you would normally bother with writing
is it that important like I don't think
so yeah okay thank you Thanks
like a bunch of more tooling questions
let's start with an easy one can we push
for J unit 5 support and enter drill
plugin because right now you have to use
search party plugin written by some guy
which every Android Gradle plugin
reviews obviously breaks and all that
and like Gradle 4.6 made the J unit 5
work out of the box and all that can we
do that sounds like a very reasonable
request yes alright now to the harder
ones so it will ring me up yeah there
was a question about instant run right
can we please make it a command-line
tool
Loren's done an integration into this
video is right now 3 major build systems
like basil but Gradle like basil and
Buck has their own ways of incrementing
someone epic a Gradle hasn't one enters
here has one and that's like mismatch
yeah so in the new implementation we're
not hooking into the Gradle bytecode
transformation pipeline ok it's done at
runtime a bit like the profiler does
instrumentation so it should be easier
but again it's not something we're
deliberately designing for but you know
we're trying to not to do that harder
one now so
let me put it that way
who knows how to contribute to ASB well
who is not Googler oh so that quit just
wins for the question yeah see as he
configure like but particularly it was
Android KTX project right like there
wasn't announcement that it was moved
from github to ASB and for some reason
people were happy but that's not true
like it's really hard to contribute a
speech really hard to pull it I like
skeet hub yeah yeah and a lot of
projects from Google are already on
github can we as a community ask for
this push for like some of the libraries
maybe please do actually like on other
Android X migration when we were
internal discussing moving to ASP sort
of like internally developing and
syncing I was a big proponent and I said
look if you put this on a SP like plenty
of people will contribute no one sends a
CL so like we understand there still a
barrier but we simplified it
significantly and we understand there's
a Garrett repo like tools people are not
very familiar with but we also have an
internal integration like with the next
version of Android like we need to stay
in the same bill 3 to make these easy oh
there you go that calendar at Chilam for
Android X we checked out the Android X
repo from AOSP on to the two machines
that we have over at the Android X booth
in about five minutes and we're up and
running to upload commits so if you want
to contribute just go ahead and do the
next room and write so yeah
cool sound scalable so there's there's
like all right there's a difference to
like when you say AOSP when we think of
AOSP contributions in platformer yes
that is a big deal and we don't expect
it a lot of people are going to absorb
the entire platform and be able to
contribute it especially since we don't
release the source code until the
release is out but the smaller libraries
like Android X like we're actually
developing an AOSP
we would like contributions and we hope
that that's low weight enough for we
would love to contribute please do yeah
so get together with Alan sort of figure
out what the disconnects are on being
able to do that because the intention
was to make it much more possible
some of the projects were able to
succeed at that like dagger for example
and you have tooling to sync it back to
your mana repos I know that like you
know I think is be is like not the part
of mana Reaper Google but still is a
mono repo so you should be able to sync
it back can I ask a question yes uh so
we could make contributing to AOSP
easier we could also consider github I'm
curious what you all would like to see
us do how many people would be
interested in seeing us put Android X on
github Wow okay how many would like to
see us just make a OSP easier okay thank
you that was very helpful
Thanks Thanks hi hi so I work at a
company that does smart connected
devices which means that I have had the
joy of interacting with the Bluetooth
API I also implemented barcode scanning
recently in the app which means I had
the joy of interacting with the camera
API my you consider the different job
only everyday he's regretting his life
choices so many of them so my question
is with the the GSIS
there was this kind of notion of pulling
things away from the OEMs and putting
them in in Google controllable land and
you know there's there's lore from from
many many years ago of like you know oh
you only run bluetooth operations on
samsung
on the main thread if you don't Samsung
phones just you know poop on you or like
modern phones don't support camera2 api
is even though they were you know made
this decided century is there an effort
or can there be an effort to move all of
this junk that happens on the cameras
and bluetooth into google controllable
and so that it's not om dependent so
this might be a little for looking but
there is there's an effort around camera
specifically to try to have sort of a
higher level api that ships as part of
the x libraries that sort of smooth
those differences between OEMs what
about Bluetooth because that's like
that's almost even worse yeah that's
probably need there in fact a lot of we
suggest a lot of if you can use it
because it is a limited API that you use
the nearby API is because they kind of
hide a lot of the messiness of the
underlying implementation and we
actually check the quality there's api's
on different devices
if not we can certainly take it back to
the bluetooth team and share your pain
so let us know but like that's not the
nearby api's don't give you the ability
to like send blue to the packets and we
actually communicate with a smartlock
that i'm trying to unlock like on
someone's door there right like that's
that's not that's not what those api's
are meant for yeah but like i don't want
to have to remember that oh with i'm on
a samsung phone i have to switch to the
main thread all other you know devices i
don't have to switch to the main thread
except for LG which just like doesn't
work so you know all of this nonsense
why you know this this should be
something that google controls why is
that something that the OEMs
get to decide on my life
I'm gonna take this one uh no response
it is pretty complicated right like
there's the Bluetooth standard isn't
totally complete or unambiguous about
how certain devices should behave so
there's you'll see a lot of variability
between OEM devices now some of the
stuff you're describing seems kind of
pointless so I can take it back to the
Bluetooth team and talk to them about
one of these we've been doing over the
last couple years is really trying to
improve Bluetooth implementation across
the ecosystem including like a rewrite
at the Bluetooth stack working with our
soci vendors and stuff like that
all those platitudes aside it sounds
like there is this gap on the developer
side that we need to address and I'm
happy to take it back to the team I
don't know of anything that they're
doing specifically to address this like
I do on the camera side but speaking of
platitude Bluetooth has gotten way
better since Android 7-ups so thank you
guys for cool it's getting better at
least yeah if you can follow up
afterwards with more details that'd be
awesome we are running out of time I'm
sorry for all the people that have been
standing there for a while if you can
ask really quick questions we'll try to
get to as many as we can before there's
Ted can I ask one question - yes please
you can take them first I can what they
can go first it's okay I'm showing my
gratitude first because I have a
compliance request so most of time on
edit studio it works fine but sometime
even though I refactor let's say
variable name it doesn't pick up an XML
file yeah so we are specifically trying
to address this with project marble okay
second thing like the classes you
generate are in the bun package so what
happens is like all the internal classes
let's say viewmodel or inside support
classes I have to make them public
because they are not accessible into the
XML file or in the data binding
generated classes no actually you could
when you have a layout file you can give
it a class name so if you specify the
class name you will generate the layout
file in the binding it will be have that
class name with the package you provide
it but the data binding generated class
they are not package specific they are
not one place
they are if you specify the package name
that they will be there but like find me
afterwards if maybe I didn't get the
question third thing like if some error
happens it shows like two hundred plus
error which is hard to sometimes you
know take some time can we make that
less than 200 errors that is a Java C
problem we haven't foreseen a we can not
work round without breaking our API I
wish I knew this like four years ago we
would design something differently we
might like I'm getting this so many
times that we might actually just break
some of the API to work around that
problem like some easy we're over time
already is it really quick fine in XML
can you put some convenience methods so
that we don't have to put the business
logic in let's say if null then visible
not visible if we can free import some
static function and we can really use
them like really small set of functions
yeah let's talk offline okay Steph did
you have one quick oh yeah one question
that came out of the community in
advance of this summit was people had
questions about how we think about the
store and apps on the store we talked
about it in the keynote people were just
wondering like what's the reasoning for
when we take apps down how can I reach
out if there's been a mistake
so I actually invited some friends of
mine to come like Paul I think it I was
wondering if any people did have that
question if you'd like to hear Paul talk
about it because they have certainly
thought about it and yes would people
like to hear Paul into that question
he's great by the way ok no pressure no
pressure so sometimes we take apps down
from the store user safety is really
really important and we're a marketplace
we need all of you to create awesome
apps and games and we need users to come
and if we don't have either side of the
ecosystem we don't have a store we don't
have an Android so we really appreciate
everything that all of you do to create
great apps and games there are a handful
of bad actors in the world some of them
are really bad and some of them are
accidentally doing bad things and we we
have a set of policies in place to
protect our users and some of these
policies also protect good developers
from having their stuff you know
inappropriate
used so we try really hard to not have
any false positives and to not make any
mistakes in our enforcement if we do
make mistake you can appeal we look at
every appeal and try to do so within a
day or two and I think you can expect
over the you know next you know quarters
we've announced so we are looking at you
know further improving the safety and
privacy on the Android in play and we
are gonna do our best to all of you in
business and keep our users safe Thanks
let me check real quick with the crew
we're running into lunchtime right now
is it possible to run over and take a
couple more questions or do we need to
shut up we say five more minutes five
more minutes
okay thank you really quick yes please
I've been doing a drug TV for three
months due to sign constraints I could
not use lean back so I had to do two
fields met manually I was hoping for a
better ways to override a focus finder
sometimes i when i refresh things
there's nothing to focus on anymore or
if you Peck Conway and stories are for
suggesting more work Adam having geez go
ahead and find us in the general
question area afterwards I want to know
some more about this okay thanks yes hi
thanks for the event I have two
questions first of them is more generic
one so I hear a bacon library is being
deprecated so what is the future of
location detection based on beacons
[Music]
that's a good question I mean you could
still you can still do ble scans and use
those scans for for location beacon
based location using nearby and what we
deprecated was the nearby notifications
stuff which was basically the issue was
you know the potential for spam or user
abuse through people just posting you
know inappropriate URLs or whatever on
these beacons and then people getting
notifications about them constantly so
you should still be able to use ble
scanning to do beacon based location
applications and we do that I mean I
don't think we that you do it directly
but
or it's that kind of work in in other
apps that are that are doing this kind
of thing okay thank you so the second
question is more specific to data mining
so yeah a fireside chat um they do I
need in your API so write in binding
adapters in Java requires static
modifier and writing them in Catalan
isn't so it's not supposed to but it
didn't work for me unless I did JVM
static annotation but in the
documentation it doesn't say that I am
required to do so yeah maybe we should
fix the documentation it's like if you
write it as an extension function on the
wheel Copland ends up generating a
static function then data mining picks
it up automatically like it works by
mistake it wasn't intended to and but
like it's really nice because you're
binding adaptors are actually extension
functions on the actual wheel like a
much more convenient way to declare them
but I guess we need to fix the
documentation it's not very like you
still need them to be static or like a
complete dynamic but it goes through
data binding component which I think I'm
gonna deprecated to fix that Java C
problems are okay I will get that fixed
thing thank you two minutes left I'm
Christian when will is there any plan
that hammer to a PU I will be in the
jetpack we stick better interface and
when will the camera API one is actually
be gone it's been deprecated for a while
I can't speak to when it'll actually be
gone hopefully soon I think the reason
we kept it around was to better support
low-end devices that there were on
chipsets that can support camera2 api
but the plan is to eventually have it be
gone I can't really speak to details on
the plans for including the new camera
API is in the jet pack because it's
again it's sort of work-in-progress and
you know stuff that we're looking at but
we are keenly interested in because we
know that a lot of apps
you know they want to get sort of the
best picture out of the camera and
they're having to resort to things like
screen scraping and stuff like that is
that writing too much called on our side
yeah yeah so we're it's a high priority
for us we're aware of it just stay tuned
hopefully next developer summit will
have something better to say about it
great thank you does that mean in three
years
thanks yes three years four I was late
to hopefully this wasn't already asked
oh let me just summarize what we've been
talking about Phyllis all right
data-binding right so Play services is
and firebase as well to an extent is
this sort of huge monolithic black box
that crashes a lot and has no bug
reporter is there anything on your radar
to improve that sort of feedback loop
like yeah it's really frustrating
whenever you have an issue and it's kind
of you know we know people in the
community who work directly on like
Android X or frameworks but as far as
like Play services or firebase is just
sort of well you can kind of dump it
into the I'm gonna stop you there cuz
we're about to run out of time is there
anybody that can handle that question on
Play services crashing I mean I work
with them a lot and we and some of my
colleagues here do too as well we
they've been working really hard to
reduce the number of crashes and Google
Play services they've actually made a
lot of progress but it is kind of a
volume game in a sense right like they
look at kind of the crashes that are
most frequent and focus on those if
you're looking at crashes that are
induced by certain uses of the Google
Play SDK I think that'd be I could talk
offline afterwards if you want and I can
get you connected at the right people
yeah I think me main concerns it's not
clear where to file bug reports so Zak
it's so you're basically asking I'd like
to a good way to file bug reports for
Play services and firebase yeah okay
yeah we can mention it thank you thank
you last question I had two questions
but I lost just one okay firstly I'd
like to say that I'm new to Android and
it's really good that we have the Google
samples and in every possible
combination with our X Java whether live
data so that's really good but I was
recently working on
for dynamic feature and I did everything
right and still nothing was working
because I there was some issue with the
flavors in our app so can we have more
real-world app samples as well to
reflect such things no world samples
it's good requests there are many many
Deverell people here who work on stuff
so that's certainly good feedback for
that team it'd be good to get the
details on the specific problem that you
had and that would be a good use case
for us too okay if you could follow up
with us thank you thanks everybody for
coming thanks to the panel and thanks
for the people in the audience as well
[Applause]
[Music]